[Music]
on this friday night from washington d.c
the political winds
keep swirling joe biden expands his lead
donald trump remains defiant and the
ballot counting
continues i think what the president
needs to do is
frankly put his big boy pants on we look
at how voters switched from trump to
biden in some swing states
plus how personal grief shaped biden's
public life
i found the best way through pain and
laws and grief
is to find purpose and how trump
supporters feel about biden
talking to you remind me to clean my gun
but i'm gonna be ready for them trust me
plus whole foods gets roasted over
[Music]
poppies
national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
from washington where it is now friday
evening and americans still aren't sure
who will be the next president ballots
are still being counted
and a few key states remain too close to
call it appears joe biden is closer to
victory than donald trump
his lead in nevada is widening he's
pulled ahead in georgia too and in
pennsylvania the state trump can't
afford to lose a win in any of those
states for biden would get him to the
270 electoral college votes
needed to win the white house right now
according to the associated press
numbers which we are using biden remains
at 264
donald trump at 214. here's what's
happening in pennsylvania
biden is now ahead by more than 14 000
votes that lead is expected to grow
as more absentee ballots are counted
trump needed
a win there for any shot at a second
term
joe biden is planning a prime time
speech tonight we're told donald trump
has issued another statement claiming
illegal ballots are being counted and
saying he will never give up fighting
our washington bureau chief jackson
proskow is with me again jackson it
seems we're just in a holding pattern
now we really are at this point donna
the results continue to trickle in and
essentially what's happening is that joe
biden's lead continues to grow
in pennsylvania in nevada and in georgia
it's shrinking slightly in arizona where
he still has the lead but in all four of
these states
the number of outstanding ballots means
that in theory if you had a huge swing
toward one candidate or the other
things could tip so people aren't
necessarily making the call yet in these
states
which means we continue to wait on
results which means the counting
continues
in this very slow methodical process and
you've got both candidates injecting
themselves from the sidelines
particularly donald trump who tweeted
tonight
that he could be claiming victory and
joe biden shouldn't claim victory
of course trump has repeatedly claimed
to have won the presidency over the past
few days despite that not being a firm
thing yet donna
and the tension continues to ratchet up
at these vote counting sites
as the president continues to goad his
supporters into thinking there's some
sort of voter fraud taking place when
there isn't
and jackson the trump team has launched
a number of legal challenges how are
those going
not well for the trump team i can tell
you at this point one was thrown out by
a judge for being
hearsay within hearsay in the words of
the judge another one fell apart after
the lead plaintiff essentially retracted
her complaint it was chalked up to
confusion
in georgia republicans said they were
going to produce specific evidence of
voter fraud at a press conference and
then
never did and in pennsylvania
republicans are going to the supreme
court
to try and force the state to do
something it's already doing which is to
set aside late arriving ballots and not
count them
and even if they were counted donna it's
such a small pile of ballots it's not
going to change the outcome here okay
jackson thanks everyone wants to know
how this story will end but
we knew before election day that all the
mail-in ballots made it likely the
counting was going to take time
we also know donald trump hates to lose
eric sorenson looks at how america got
to this point
donald trump signaled months ago the war
he was willing to wage to claim victory
there's a lot of fraudulent voting going
on in this country he told his
supporters to vote in person
on election day and they did just that
and those votes counted first
put him ahead and that's when trump
wanted the buzzer to end the game
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
[Applause]
but millions of mail-in ballots were
still to be counted democrats had urged
a broad coalition to vote early
to be counted later it's imperative that
we all get out and vote
that's the message but would it make a
difference
on election night as states were called
there was a sense of deja vu as with
four years ago it seemed like the polls
had missed donald trump's actual support
as red republican states piled up by the
time
florida at 12 34 in the morning and
texas was called just before 1am
the first 41 states had been declared
exactly as they'd gone in 2016. and
donald trump was leading once more in
the main battleground states in the
southeast
and the midwest it was hillary clinton
in 2016 all over again
but then arizona began looking good for
joe biden
and associated press called it the next
afternoon wisconsin
followed by michigan going to biden and
then pennsylvania
and even georgia in the deep south moved
toward biden
and it was clear 2020 was not a repeat
of 2016.
the democrats campaign to bank early
ballots began adding up
these are all mail ballots that are
still being counted and reported out joe
biden would get an
unheard of number of votes but from whom
after four years of donald trump a broad
coalition found common cause
black voters who sat out 2016 voted in
droves in cities like detroit and
atlanta
it's the most important election of my
lifetime we're to heal
that's why we have to come together but
biden was also breaking new ground
with hispanic voters in conservative
arizona with women in philadelphia's
suburbs
and making history in the deep south
with a cross section of black and young
voters in georgia
this is definitely important this is how
we get heard
america right now america is very
divided
on identity or demographic lines but
there was a
lot a strong sense among democrats that
this is an important election
and donald trump needs to be defeated in
a post-trump era republicans may have to
adjust
as populations that are diverse and
growing have found a home for now
with the democrats eric sorensen global
news
jackson tens of millions america of
americans did vote for donald trump and
even if
joe biden is declared the winner donald
trump is still in charge
until the inauguration could that be an
unsettling time
yeah i mean there are big questions
about what the next 75 days will look
like regardless of who the next
president is going to be or if it's
going to be donald trump
uh you know it's not clear that the
president for example if he loses would
cooperate with the transition process
very traditionally defined in its roles
in the way it works
it's not clear for example at this point
if he would do anything to help an
incoming administration settle into the
job
and then there's the more practical
realities of the situation on the ground
here in the u.s right now as it relates
to the kovid 19 pandemic
the president has shown no interest in
changing course and yet
the trajectory here is absolutely awful
yesterday 120
000 cases more than 1100 deaths and
donna as of right now there are more
than
52 000 americans currently hospitalized
the peak continues to climb at a rapid
pace here
all right jackson frosco thank you
pennsylvania is still
in the spotlight for donald for donald
trump there is no path to the white
house if he doesn't win
it but it's still too early to call and
those counting the ballots know the
whole world is watching our mike
armstrong is in philadelphia tonight
where the pressure
is intense as if anxiety levels weren't
high enough around the counting in this
city's convention center
philadelphians woke up this morning to
news that operation
may have been the target of a planned
attack
this was the scene outside thursday
night two men were taken into custody
police say they were tipped off to a
group of individuals from
out of state possibly armed headed to
philadelphia to disrupt the counting in
some way
inside their vehicle stickers for the
conspiracy group q anon
what this city also woke up to was a
very tight race with donald trump in the
lead
that flipped to biden at about 8 50.
[Music]
there was in some neighborhoods elation
but in most
simply a sense of hope this could be
winding down
a little relief but still just waiting
to see what happens
now biden's come from behind to take the
lead was predicted for weeks democrats
were telling supporters to vote early
basically banking votes there you go
these women worked at polling stations
they say they weren't busy on election
day
because so many people had already voted
i voted by mail everybody i
know and i voted by the house voted by
mail so
we're not surprised now the trump
campaign has been alleging some sort of
fraud is going on in the counting
process there is no proof of that
they're arguing they have access to
observe but that they're being kept
too far away and that corrupt things may
or
are going on out of sight even some who
endorse the president aren't buying the
distance proves corruption that's a real
problem that should be fixed that's
that's not right
but it's not proof that there's
widespread fraud or theft it'd be
it's it's it's not likely at all county
officials insist
everything is above board they even have
this 24-hour day
live stream of what's going on the mayor
of philadelphia says the charges of
corruption
should stop you know i think what the
president needs to do is
frankly put his big boy pants on he
needs to acknowledge the fact that he
lost
and he needs to congratulate the winner
the charged rhetoric and tension haven't
been dampened by biden taking the lead
but this state and this country may have
dodged a bullet
with biden now leading in enough states
to win the electoral college without
pennsylvania
the entire u.s election won't hinge on
what happens
here mike armstrong global news
philadelphia
donald trump is questioning the
legitimacy of the ballot counting
process and many of his supporters are
following his lead
jeff semple is in detroit michigan
tonight
[Applause]
donald trump supporters of all stripes
gathered in downtown detroit
united in anger we're going to expose
them
lock them up echoing the president's
unsubstantiated claims that the election
was stolen what'd you say what are you
going to do if they declare biting the
way
i'm talking to you remind me to clean my
gun but i'm going to be ready for them
trust me
the democrats won michigan by around 146
thousand votes have you seen any
evidence of fraud yet
there's fraud if you cannot look at the
ballots some republican poll watchers
like this woman
claim they were prevented from
inspecting the ballots they hate
that i challenge every ballot on that
table
so they try everything they could to
kick me out of there others point to
claims circulating online
such as this viral video that purports
to show someone arriving with a wagon of
ballots in the middle of the night
a man rolling a wagon into the tcf
center here yesterday turns out it was
actually a local news cameraman
the video debunked by his network the
wagon we have it right here this is what
it looks like it was carrying as it is
now
equipment it's only evidence of the
freaking media says it's evidence
the chairwoman of the republican
national committee is now calling on
journalists to investigate the michigan
vote
and that any irregularities that have
occurred whether by
malicious intent or incompetence are
fully investigated
what do you think it's going to take for
trump supporters to accept
the election result i think a little
healthy dose of reality this local
republican candidate who won his
township north of detroit believes his
party needs to accept the outcome
even if they prevailed in pennsylvania
and georgia
he's not close enough in the other races
to merit
a real a real challenge back in detroit
tensions flared as counter protesters
arrived
prompting police to step in at one point
after shouting across the barricades
a militia member walked over to a black
lives matter protester
and gave him a hug absolutely that was a
hug
that was open dialogue a rare moment of
unity in a deeply divided nation
jeff semple global news detroit
whole foods bags a whole lot of
criticism coming up why would the
supermarket chain
ban poppies
welcome back to washington kovic 19
continues to spread at an alarming rate
in this country
and in canada there are now 34 000
active cases and that number is climbing
quebec recorded more than a thousand new
cases today and 25 more people died
a similar situation in ontario where
this week's average hit a new record
high
nearly a thousand cases a day out west
bc set another record today
589 cases saskatchewan also broke a
record with 129
and none of it canada's last virus-free
jurisdiction
confirmed its first case of covet 19.
there is new data on jobs today there
are six hundred thousand
fewer paid jobs in canada today compared
to february
and as david aiken reports it could take
a vaccine to allow the bulk of those
people
to go back to work i can't stress this
enough
this situation is serious prime minister
justin trudeau is worried about
rising coven 19 case counts single day
records for new cases
were set thursday in bc and saskatchewan
and in ontario
a single day record for this second wave
was set on wednesday
overall canada is now seeing an average
of more than
3 300 new cases a day these are not just
numbers
these are people's grandparents parents
and loved ones
including the prime ministers i just got
news last night that my
godfather and uncle tom walker
had to be readmitted to hospital last
night
but while coven 19 case data is
troubling new
jobs data out friday was more
encouraging
the economy added 84 000 new jobs
in october bringing the unemployment
rate down a tick
to 8.9 percent we're making progress
but there's still much more work to be
done
indeed the number of long-term
unemployed remains
stubbornly high there are 450 000
canadians
who have been looking for a job
continuously since
april both sets of data the number of
new coven 19 cases
and the number of long-term jobless will
only really start to drop
when a vaccine is available and on that
front some hope
i am cautiously optimistic that safe and
effective covert 19 vaccines
will be available in the first quarter
of 2021
bringing us one step closer to the
widespread and long-term management of
cobin 19.
a new task then for the federal
government to make some decisions about
who gets access to the vaccine first
trudeau says a plan is in the works one
that will be developed
with the provinces donna
okay david aiken in ottawa thank you
whole foods is changing its tune
on poppies after facing a big backlash
the amazon owned company
had banned employees from wearing
poppies because it violated the
company's new dress code
you can imagine how that went down
canada's veterans affairs minister had a
chat with the ceo of whole foods and
he reversed the policy employees at all
14 canadian locations are
now allowed to wear poppies it is the
flower that won our piece
and there was an awful lot of fellows
died
to give us the freedoms we've got and
this is our salute to them
whole foods now says it never meant to
single out the poppy in its new dress
code
or suggest it wasn't supporting
remembrance day and canada's veterans
the need for speed still ahead how a
luxury sports car is helping save lives
in italy
global national is back from washington
in a moment
a humanitarian disaster is unfolding in
honduras tonight as heavy rain from
hurricane etta triggers flooding
mudslides and a desperate rescue mission
at least 57 people are known to have
died
the storm has weakened to a tropical
depression but it's still hitting a
large swath
of central america
that includes guatemala at least 100
people have died in mudslides there
rescue operations in the remote
mountainous villages have been slowed by
destroyed roads and bridges authorities
have called in the military and
helicopters and speed boats are also
being used
to help rescue people in italy police
use the fastest tool in their arsenal to
move a kidney across the country for
life-saving surgery
officers delivered the organ in time by
using their lamborghini hurricane
reaching speeds of up to 230 kilometers
an hour they arrived at the hospital in
rome in just over two hours
the 500 kilometer journey would normally
take about six hours if you didn't
happen to have a lamborghini
handy not your average joe next how
politics and pain
is shaped joe biden
we're back from washington in a moment
2020 could be third time lucky for joe
biden this is the third time he has
sought the u.s presidency
his public life has been shaped by
private grief and now
days before his 78th birthday he's
poised to possibly take over
one of the toughest jobs in the world
joe biden has spent his entire adult
life in public life
including two terms as barack obama's
vice president
talk about our bromance
born in scranton pennsylvania his dad
fixed furnaces and sold
cars blue collar roots he says shaped
him
his political start was in 1972 in
delaware
hi how are you he was 29
full of confidence and married with
three kids then
just before christmas his life fell
apart his wife and baby daughter
died in a car crash his boys bow and
hunter were injured
you knew you just felt it in your bones
something bad happened there will come a
day
i promise you and your parents as well
when the thought of your son or daughter
or your husband or wife
brings a smile to your lips before it
brings a tear to your eye
some politicians learn about despair
biden
lived it he considered resigning but
with family support and faith in god he
stayed in politics
he took the oath of office from his
son's hospital room
in 1977 he married again in 1987 he was
a prominent figure in washington
these people are being crushed and made
his first attempt to run for president
i honest to god believe i'll be the next
president of the united states of
america
come on honest to god he was 44 and ran
on a message of generational change
but those who covered him say his mouth
was both his greatest asset
and his greatest liability and i'd be
delighted to sit down and compare my iq
to yours if you'd like frank
he was accused of plagiarizing speeches
he inflated his academic record
and falsely claimed he'd marched in the
civil rights movement
i've done some dumb things and i'll do
dumb things again
he dropped out of that race and at times
he's struggled to appear
like he's in step with the times he's
been accused of getting too
touchy feely with women and had to
apologize
but i will be more mindful and
respectful of people's personal space
in 2008 he tried for the presidential
nomination
again can you reassure your voters in
this country that you would have the
discipline you would need
on the world stage senator yes
but he never gained traction after he
withdrew obama chose him as his running
mate
for decades he's brought change to
washington but
washington hasn't changed him he's an
expert on foreign policy whose heart
and values are firmly rooted in the
middle class in 2015 he faced another
devastating loss when his son beau died
from brain cancer
at the age of 46. biden has cast himself
as a steady
seasoned hand in an uncertain world even
his critics can't deny he has experience
and empathy but if he becomes president
his greatest test is yet to come
and that is global national for this
friday from washington d.c i'm donna
friesen
thanks for watching i'll see you
tomorrow night on the new reality right
here on global
take care of yourselves bye-bye
you